[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
devoir nous faire le meilleur le
meilleur des filets et une telle bombe
est mouillé d'accord la syrie vous êtes
sensuelle vous êtes beau oui laisser les
micros pour l'instant apprise en voilà
les chéris attention est ce que
attention attention tout sur la syrie
quand je vous le dis est ce que vous
êtes prête
ouais ouais on va voir déjà le premier
le premier arrivant le 1er je vais
demander à christophe carrière de
démarrer mais venez venez plus près il
fallait bien mais attention
christophe carrière c'est parti à moi
j'ai très envie d'aller bien chez vous
un peu
mais n'a pas si près
[Rires]
voilà un décor ce christophe carrière
alors les filles comment on l'a trouvé
très bien on s'en bat les mois passés du
rêve au cauchemar
jean fernandez numéro deux à la trace
bien quand même
[Musique]
il
je ne suis pas du tout
il habitait jeu trajet l'eau et le corps
et ce programme serait très beau corps
j'ai une vraie attention on va passer à
maxime johnny benjamin castaldi benjamin
castaldi aller benji
fra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas mal c'est le même
[Musique]
benjamin castaldi
3 les trois sont très bobo est en
retrait dit c'est des mecs vont
m'impressionner
et vous êtes-vous en novembre
franchement les téléspectateurs et les
téléspectatrices et parce qu'ils on
pense très très gros des trois comme ça
en blanc tel bolide illustre on va
passer fils gilles gagné à jean michel
bélot terminera par le coup attention
c'est parti on y va jean richard ellis
et la beauté tranquille
la bronche pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons arrêté nous arrive à tous il
a rien compris en principe c'est un
cocon de ces championnats
regardez tout seul je me tais par
respect j'ai arrêté de me cracher dessus
allez allez chercher merci mais il a
donné un coma jean michel a franchement
bravo jamais ça ne m'est pas dégueulasse
mais non mais non c'est rien ça
attention il y vit on va terminer
alors comment vous l'avez trouvée sur
michelle obama la séparation plaît pas
tout en même temps je trouve ça un
meilleur roi que trois romans un peu
trop jeune mais là n'est pas le meilleur
c'est parce que vous allez devoir
choisir deux mois qu'ils vont faire
ensuite une dernière dans son final
devant vous attention le dernier maxime
gagné c'est parti c'est pas pousser
amal a pas mal
pas mal comment ça marche cette merde
très bien mais c'est maxime qui dit non
à ces indices est un délit la sadc
pluies deviendront alors les chais pour
qui vous allez devoir chacune en sauver
deux dakar en faire une dernière danse
attention géraldine mali moi je sauve
benjamin castaldi
oui gilles verdez j'ai vu pareil dans sa
main agile vos pareils benjamin gille et
vous jean-mi pour la générosité et
gilles pour la bonne surprise vient donc
c'est pas jamais jamais jamais la chance
vous avez de la chance vous aurez la
chance nationale
il était bien géré et gilles et on va
prendre quelqu'un en lui qui va désigner
son favori si on devait couper en quatre
on a on à charlotte en ligne s'allume à
charlotte à lui comment tu les trouveras
sarr l'autre
franchement ils sont très nombreux et
voilà on est dehors rockliffe un peu
savent agents mis ses bons mettez vous
sur le côté il acte et je vous remercie
à gérer à ton avis qui va gagner auprès
des fils au concours de t-shirt mouillé
[Musique]
il
jude alors attention elle pense que
c'est gênant mais vous de vous allez
être honnête
attention c'est parti vous allez devoir
faire une dernière danse mais là vous
donner tout ce que vous avez
non ça car autour ça les fait le fait de
lois faites l'ont sorti fat l'assemblée
on les moineaux censé parquet va bien
sûr vous l'aimiez attention 3,2 à ces
partis
ouais
[Musique]
arrêtez vos plus loin
la lady
julie tremblay
[Musique]
pour m
ohlala yeux
m
[Musique]
ça va pas bien arrêtez tout arrêter tous
les chérit les geler si les filles
venaient là on défile on est là pour
vous et l'autre l'hautil encore posséder
est encore en train de danser chez vous
je crois que les valeurs mais c'est
n'importe quoi
les chérit les chéris allez donnez moi
ces derniers mois ces pistolets vous
avez encore de l'eau c'est bon c'est bon
ah oui voila voila merci disperser la
foule merci merci les séries merci ah
oui alors les les cherry à votre avis à
votre avis qui a été payant qui était
meilleure pour moi c'est gilles bon mois
selon les zones et benji pour vous pour
moi c'est gilles même si ce gênant quand
il danse provost cgil
il a tout donné on va faire mieux gérald
gilles et bien ma chérie tu repars avec
un magnifique cadeau c'est quoi le
cadeau on cherche à me dire ça il le
sait pas non dit maintien rappelle toi
c'est quoi ta blait coucher tard mais
oui d'accord une tablette tu parais
qu'une tablette ma chérie ça va
[Musique]